[Music]
[Applause]
oh holy moly new graphics huh
video did you did the graphics
department is is on top of it this week
it's like somebody's paying me i guess
so no no they're not no no one's paying
the gravity department
they work they work for free here at the
johnny michaels podcast welcome to
bonehead of the week
your edition you guys vote
you decide who is the bone net of the
week and we break it down for you i'm
speaking that here is bone of the week
and and to just tell all the listeners
out there who are just listening to bone
end of the week because we actually post
bone head of the week on youtube uh of
its own video that way if you guys miss
bone of the week you can watch it
separately so all of you out there
watching bone in the week right now that
didn't watch the episode the five hour
episode that it appears that this is
going to be this week
cut this out right right we will cut
bone into the week out but if you're
watching just bone of the week know that
it's probably going to be a short
version
because what we're doing today is we're
listening in on the insurrection hearing
of marjorie taylor green and we're
giving commentary as that goes so this
is a special edition episode on this
friday
april 22nd
and so we may or may not have a long
bone of the week but to get to it here
marjorie taylor green is on this list
because
because today's episode because of
today's episode so we'll skip over that
if you want to find out more about why
marjorie taylor green is a bonehead
i i mean just google marjory taylor
green you'll figure it out um but moving
to the next bonehead of the week is uh
greg abbott
greg abbott is the governor of texas
well sort of
i mean sort of don't you think yeah
i mean if anything he's um
he's a literal drain on our
tax our tax money our gdp
i think of what it was nine billion his
whole stunt has cost uh that is the
reason why i wanted him
because he won
he won bonehead of the week last week if
you recall and the reason why he won
bone in the week last week is because he
was emptying grocery store shelves he
was destroying hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of produce because he
wanted to manufacture a crisis so that
people would blame it on joe biden
and he cost the state of texas and he
cost the united states this week we find
out almost 9 billion dollars and that my
friends is the reason why he's on
bonehead of the week this week so his
cause and effect last week he won
because of the cause this week he's on
because of the fact and we'll find out
if he won or not but here's the thing
here's the thing that republicans are
going to do
he he cost us 9 billion dollars in the
united states and what the republicans
are gonna do they're going to tax you
they're gonna tax you to try to get that
nine billion dollars back they already
have a tax plan and um that several are
running around the country bragging
about that's gonna that's gonna tax you
forty five hundred dollars more so the
middle class is gonna pay for that nine
billion dollars but which brings me to
which brings me to another one of our
boneheads here um
another one of our bone and speaking of
republicans wanting to tax their
citizens and the constituents ron
desantis has decided it's a good idea to
tax folks over uh this his fight with
mickey mouse well he wants to he wants
to pass the book because disney has a
tax incentive to be where they are right
and also keep in mind that disney is a
huge money-making machine for the state
of florida jobs uh i mean basically he
says
yeah do not come do not come to the most
visited place in florida do not come
here and spend your money you stay out
of the state because disney's woke or
whatever
whatever craziness that they're trying
to spend here because disney's on the
side of equality because that's what's
happened they passed the do not say gay
bill uh in florida and the the actual
story is is that disney was not against
the don't say gay bill at first um as a
company they actually funded some of the
groups that were kind of behind the
don't say gay bill and when the
employees of disney world found out
about this they decided that they would
say well if you support this bill now
now that we know that you did support it
and now that we know that you won't be
against it we will walk out we will walk
out and we and we will not work here at
disney world and and disney being the
company that they are did not want to do
that to their cast members they call
them cast members
their employees essentially
um and the ceo decided to change his
tune
and just and he actually released a
statement and not so many words he said
disney will always be on the side of
equity inequality and i made a mistake
here and we are going to be on the side
of equity equality and we want we want
florida to to basically throw the don't
say gay bill in the trash
um
i just looked it up and disney was so i
looked up the most visited place in the
us because i was curious myself you know
not only is it the most visited in uh uh
florida but
in a list of places that are the most
visited in the u.s you've got times
square central park union station so all
things within the east coast new york
area
then it's magic kingdom disney world
then disneyland resort then walt disney
world
epcot disney's animal kingdom walt
disney world disney's hollywood studios
walt disney world right so you look at
these and like in the top ten like
there's like five of them
that are all disney world specific but
gabe it's because it is disney i i
really
i really don't think that ron desantis
did a lot of political calculations
before they went on this crusade of
making disney the enemy i thought they
thought it was going to be really easy
because the left and the right has tried
to um boycott disney over the years
right yeah and boycotting a company is a
little different than a state legislator
or a governor taking legal action in
their state based on laws and rules that
are already in place in their state um
it is a lot different to say go boycott
them than to take away a special tax
status now
most people think um well
most of the maga the trump supporting
desantis supporting morons out there
think that disney is getting a tax break
through this special assessment and that
is the exact opposite that is happening
what disney world did when they went to
florida they bought huge swaziland it's
the size of approximately like five
counties like it's humongous right it's
not small and what disney said was is
instead of the state spending a lot of
money on our special service
infrastructure so
water sewer
uh power plants fire departments police
departments and security
there's just a whole host of services
that we receive as taxpayers that we
actually don't even recognize that we
get until we don't have them right
now
disney did this so that they could build
their infrastructure and they could pay
for that infrastructure as opposed to
the state of florida and their disney
would do this for a lot of reasons
number one they wanted to have control
over the upgrades of those services as
they build their parks right and then
they would expand disney world so that
makes a little bit of sense
the other thing they didn't want to do
was fight with the state over these
services so it made sense for them to
take on the cost of these special
services inside this assessed area that
is disney world that disney owns right
and and to do this what ron desantis is
wanting to do
is make sure that the state of florida
now has control over those services
which means the state of florida now has
to foot the bill so what ron desantis is
saying is because disney wants to be for
equality and equity which is something
ron desantis hates equality and equity
that we what we're going to do is we're
going to tax the citizens of florida to
make sure they're not for equality and
equity that is literally what he's
saying so if you if you are i mean if
you are a bigot and you do not like
disney because you are a bigot then the
state of florida is going to pay for
your cause but if you're someone who
really doesn't give a damn if gay people
are married or not if if lgbt
communities have their rights
and you want to go to disney and you
don't want to have to have floridians
pay for disney to have these special
services inside their their district as
it's called
then you're probably on the side of it
ron desantis is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and a
bonehead right i mean for a party that
says uh oh do your own research
ron desantis is somebody who did not
actually do his own research on this he
was like oh i'm gonna make a move that
you know what they're gonna they're
gonna balk and they're gonna they're
gonna come back and say oh we're so
sorry we apologize we really need this
meanwhile i'm not saying that disney
world could just like up and leave and
go to another state while they very well
could uh you know that realistically
that's not going to happen so anyone who
says it is i think it's a little
unrealistic right but
they
disney does have a lot of the
you know a lot of leverage here and i
think they do have the cards in their
favor
and ron desantis is going to see this
because no one can bypass the fact that
if
this does in fact have to go to
uh the buck is passed to the
constituents and the taxpayers
there's no way to to to to flip that any
any other way right you're like oh
this company said they support lgbtq ron
desantis doesn't and as a result now
we remove this
uh right yeah special assessment and now
you guys have to pay an extra two to
three k i don't mean to cut you off gabe
yeah we're gonna have this hearing
coming back uh one thing i want to do
before we give the winner his due i want
to talk about our alpha kevin mccarthy
because just as we're seeing in in this
hearing with marjorie taylor green the
lying the outright lying the reason why
we made uh kevin mccarthy the alpha cuck
of the week is because kevin mccarthy
was lying about what he said what he
didn't say because the recording came
out last night uh rachel maddow played
it on msnbc and it sounds like more came
while we've been on this whole course
there's more more has come out right so
so uh kevin mccarthy he really is
probably i mean he's the alpha cuck of
the week but he's probably the scumbag
of the week as well right and it's not
surprising with these republicans um of
the lying and seeing what marjorie
taylor green but let's go to the winner
let's give the winner his due the winner
is greg abbott believe it or not you
guys voted for my surprise i really
thought i really thought um oh oh no
wait was that right
i don't think so that's why i'm
surprised i think you did it wrong oh i
get it wrong
who is it's ron desantis right it's ron
desantis give me a second give me one
ron desantis is the winner yes um of the
bonehead of the week let's give him his
due and then we'll play your slide here
[Music]
so i i didn't actually have the um the
uh
the ability to look at this beforehand
and double check you did you just pull
because i think you pulled the slide
from last week didn't you oh my gosh
what is going this is what happens when
you're trying to multitask watching this
question i know i know because we are we
are we are trying to monitor the
marjorie taylor green uh insurrection
hearing now speaking of bonus she was on
the bone end of the week this week for
this very reason she was yes but you
guys did not did it not but you guys
chose
um
ron desantis and i am assuming you chose
ron desantis because he's a bigoted
scumbag um who hates mickey mouse this
and and since we know that he now is the
bonehead of the week
gabe would you ever get in a fight um
and especially a public relations fight
with mickey mouse
no that's so dumb i mean what the [ __ ]
was he here
like literally i understand like you
want to hate disney right like the
overall scope of things but literally
that the [ __ ] face of disney
walt disney himself made mickey mouse
the face the image of disney how in the
world do you think you're gonna win do
not mess with the mouse right
he owns the house all right so this is
the actual uh
okay the video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here's the thing here's the thing
we're going to go back to the hearing
marjorie taylor green so bone end of the
week i blame it on marjory taylor green
is ron desantis please join us next week
with bonehead of the week where you can
vote follow us at tonymichaelspod vote
there we're gonna go back to the hearing
thank you for joining us for bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign